- But the closer I get to
the ring I'm more confident.
Once I'm in the ring I'm a god.
No one could beat me.
A good fight is just to be diligent
and committed and disciplined.
Doing what you hate to do
but do it like you love it.
And I do it with passion and love,
and if you're doing this for money,
the emotional outcome is
going to be disastrous.
Not necessarily the size of the guy,
you know what I mean,
it's basically the spirit
and the competitive in his heart.
As we get older we lose our hair,
we lose our teeth, we lose our mothers.
Talent? I don't believe in talent.
Many times I've quit boxing before
I even became a professional boxer.
- He's an American former
professional boxer.
He was known for his ferocious
and intimidating boxing
style as well as his
controversial behavior
inside and outside the ring.
Nicknamed "Iron" or "Kid Dynamite"
he's considered to be one of the greatest
heavyweight boxers of all time.
He's Mike Tyson, and here is my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Number 10 is my personal favorite,
so I'm curious to find out which
one you guys like the most.
And make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonuses.
(swoosh)
While I'm in the dressing room,
five minutes before I come
out, my gloves are laced up.
I'm breaking my gloves down, I'm pushing
the leather in the back of
my - I'm breaking the middle
of the glove so my knuckle can
pierce through the leather.
I can feel my knuckle piercing
against the tight leather glove.
The Everlast boxing glove.
When I come out, I have
supreme confidence,
but I'm scared to death.
I'm totally afraid.
I'm afraid of everything.
I'm afraid of losing.
I'm afraid of being humiliated.
But I'm totally confident. The closer
I get to the ring, the
more confident I get.
The closer and more confidence I get,
the closer and more confident I get.
All during my training, I've
been afraid of this man.
I thought this man might
be capable of beating me.
I've dreamed of him beating me.
But that I would always
stay afraid of him.
But the closer I get to the
ring, I'm more confident.
Once I'm in the ring, I'm
a God. No one can beat me.
(crowd cheers)
I walk around the ring,
I never take my eyes
off my opponent. I keep my eyes on him.
Even if he's ready and
pumped and he can't wait
to get his hands on me as
well. I keep my eyes on him.
I keep my eyes on him.
The once I see a chink in his armor, boom.
And one of his eyes may move,
and then I know I have him.
Then when he comes to
the center of the ring
he still looks at me
with this piercing look
as if he's not afraid, but
he already made that mistake
when he looked down for
that one tenth of a second.
I knew I had him. He'll
fight hard for the first
two or three rounds, but I know
I already broke his spirit.
During the fight, I'm supremely confident.
I'm moving my head. He's throwing punches.
I'm making him miss and I'm countering.
I'm hitting him to the body.
I'm punching him real hard.
And I'm punching, when I'm punching
I know he's not able to take my punches.
One, two, three punches. I'm throwing
them punches in bunches. He goes down.
He's out. I'm victorious.
Mike Tyson, the greatest
fighter ever lived.
(crowd cheers)
A good fighter's not necessarily
the greatest fighter that ever lived.
It's what - where you want to go.
You know what I mean? Um, a good fight is
to just be diligent and
committed and disciplined.
Doing what you hate to do,
but do it like you love it.
You know, always testing yourself.
Forcing yourself to the limits. You know?
If you know you, um like
- if you love women?
Then deny yourself that.
You know what I mean?
That's what, um - that's
what success in general
is all about. Sacrifice.
From my experience, if
any, the little success
I may have had. Just be
willing to sacrifice. You know?
Unfortunately, sometimes
you can't have fun
accomplishing your goals.
And when - sometimes people don't have the
the determination, the will, and
the steadfastness, the tenacity.
They give into the slightest struggle.
I won't do anything unless
I'm passionate about it.
You know? I don't - I don't
care if I don't get any money -
That's what I learned
about peace and happiness,
that if you're not
doing it with a passion,
and love and you're
just doing it for money,
it's um, the emotional outcome
is going to be disastrous.
And that's from my experience.
That's just really what I know.
So I know it has to be for pure passion
and a love for what I'm doing.
- [Interviewer] As a
smaller boxer yourself,
in terms of stature, how do you take on
these big guys with the big reach?
- I don't know, it's not
necessarily the size of the guy.
You know what I mean?
It's basically the spirit
and the competitive in his heart.
If a guy wants to fight,
he could be four foot two
and fight a guy six foot nine.
If you want to fight,
you're going to fight
and you're going to do well.
That's just the average of law
here, in the game of boxing.
If you really want to do
it, you're going to do well.
But what I found out in
life, as life goes on,
life is about losing. As we
get older we lose our hair.
We lose our teeth. We lose our mothers,
our fathers, our sisters and um -
But it's the ones who
overcome their loss in life
and shun away adversity and
always willing to fight it,
every particular moment in life
are the ones that are able to transcend
and be able to spread
the word to other people
who is in that same particular
genre that they are.
In order to be great,
you know what I mean?
You have to be prepared to
to fail greatly as well.
You know, it's all about
how you handle the failures.
You know? And I'm good
at handling failures.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- And I'm good at handling
those - I don't know.
I'm probably - I'm not that
good at handling success.
I can handle failure better
than I can handle success.
- [Interviewer] (giggles)
- I feel I was born to find,
because I have no other
interest in anything else.
Anybody's a fighter in their own right.
You're a fighter. I'm a fighter.
Everyone that's in this
room, even the newspaper man.
They're fighters. But everybody
don't get up every morning and run.
Everybody don't go to
the gym every morning.
And everybody don't have enough discipline
to wait in the locker room for two hours,
or three hours, then go in the ring
and do what they've been taught
all those years in the gym.
And so, that's what separates a champion
from a mediocre fighter.
- [Interviewer] So what about talent?
- Talent? I don't believe in talent.
Well, some people they have talent,
that's - it's good, it
helps when you have talent.
But as long as you have
a lot of determination
and willpower, that's all you need.
You have to have the will to win.
- All know about your
love for Cus D'Amato.
How much of him is in you
when you're doing this?
- I don't know. I'm - I'm just not him.
Maybe, um, if I continue to do this
for another 20 years or so, I may -
I may be somewhere in there close to his
level of protection of his
fighters, but as of now, no.
I mean, it's - it's not
the - I mean, it's not
as seasoned experience
as Mister D'Mato was.
- You speak of him in the present tense.
He's very much with you at all times?
- Pretty much, yeah. Pretty much.
- Would you have him as one of the most
special people in your life?
- Absolutely. No one can
inspire me as much as he did.
If I was discouraged,
I would say, you know -
'Cause sometimes I'm sure in your field
you say well, I really -
things may have got difficult
or something may happen in your life,
I don't want to do this no more.
We all go through that. I
don't want to do this no more.
And he would inspire me to say
"Hey, this is the route to go."
He would inspire me to want to do it.
Many times I quite boxing before
I even became a professional boxer.
As an amateur I quit, I
didn't want to do it and um -
he gave me the inspiration, the reason
why I should be doing this.
- My old job was just to inflict pain
and people had in mind
the intimidation factor.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- That's the biggest aspect of anything
in life is intimidation.
Because once a person
who's a great anything
is intimidated, he can no longer perform
under the high level that he's normally
accustom to working
because he's intimidated
and he he's shut down.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- And I'm, listen, I'm the master at that.
I put it out that I'm going
to be the most intimidating
athlete in the world of sports.
Forget that - forget boxing.
The history of the world of sports.
And you have to be willing - boxing
and sports and everything,
in life, it's all about a bluff.
It's almost like playing cards.
Like, I say more-so than um -
I say more-so than I say shooting dice.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- You know?
Because you can change dices and stuff
but they can't - they're
hard, they can't mold.
- [Interviewer] Mmm hmm
- You know what I mean?
You just got to give you - you just shoot
and when you shoot - cards can bend.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- Cards can bend, like life.
Us and life, we can bend.
- [Interviewer] Mmm hmm?
- And even though we got a bad hand
that don't mean we're going
to lose the fucking game.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- We're going to stay in there
and we're going to hold on to the end.
- [Interviewer] Uh huh?
And it's the same way in fighting
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And in life.
Because we were born in the swallows
and the sewers and the gutters,
that don't mean we're going to stay there
if we have the desire, willpower,
perseverance to be able
to endure the pain.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- We got to endure that pain.
- [Interviewer] Mmm hmm
- You know?
But look at me, everybody likes me now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But I'm the last man standing
Everybody likes the last man.
- [Interviewer] What will people remember
about Mike Tyson 50 years from now?
- 50 Years? (pauses thoughtfully)
I don't know. That I'm the most ferocious,
destructive fighting
machine God every created.
Yeah, that's what I think.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Ali Hassan asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments
below and I will see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Mike Tyson's
top ten rule had the biggest
impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments.
I will join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
- (swoosh)
- Took a long time to grow up.
Really took a long time to grow up
and deal with the
responsibilities of life.
Because when you're boxing and playing
rugby and football and all
that - What are we doing?
You're living a life of rowdy.
You're living like a kid.
You don't have many responsibilities.
- What do you miss most
about the life then?
- Um
- The old days.
- I - there's not much I miss about it.
Because when you really think about it,
the height of my career, I'm making
30, 40 million a fight, doing what I want.
Anybody I want to see or meet
I see them on television.
Strange, I seem them, I like
them, I make a phone call.
I can meet anybody, do what I want to do.
But I didn't have any peace.
You know? I didn't have
peace. And now I'm at the -
I'm not even at the height of my career.
I don't make a tenth of
the money I made then.
And I've got cartoons. I have a show.
I could have never accomplished
this when I was fighting.
I would never gotten
along with the producer.
I would have been arrogant. I would -
It's just - you learn humbleness
as you get older in life.
And you learn, um - if you
don't come in this world
humble, this world will
thrust humbleness upon you.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think it's more important
to be respected or feared?
- I would like to be respected.
Respect is more powerful
than love, I believe.
You know, but how many people
out of the obligation of love,
Machiavelli, out of obligation
of love have we hurt?
Just think about it. Everybody
that's listening to me.
Out of the obligation of
love, this is my sister,
my brother, my girlfriend
that I cheated on.
My boyfriend who I didn't
tell him everything,
or else he should have
knew this not his child.
Or whatever the situation
may be. You know what I mean?
We just have to know, um -
this is what it is. You know what I mean?
Some people can get by
with just being respected.
Some people get high off of being feared.
- The Mitch "Blood" Green story
is the greatest story every told.
- It's -
- I've (expletive)
- We hope Mitch is still around.
- Yeah
- I love that story.
The best.
- In your one man show
you talk about, like, you're like
"This guy might even show up at, like -"
Did he actually have you
worried at one point?
Because -
- No because, listen.
Every time somewhere,
this guy's popping up.
- (crowd laughs)
- You know?
I'm in the hospital
because of my car accident.
He's - and they said
"Hey Mike, look outside."
I look out my hospital
window, there's a crowd
and there's the president.
He's giving an interview.
Calling me, "I have faggot Cicely Tyson,
Homo Mike Tyson this - " and holy sh-
- For those of you who don't know the
Mitch "Blood" Green story, he fought
Mitch "Blood' Green and he beat him.
Then, he like, terrorized Mike for years.
Would show up at dinners,
- Haunting me around.
- at restaurants,
- Haunting me.
- And would try to fight him.
- All the time.
- (audience laughs)
- So Mike's getting fitted
for a suit one night
(chuckles) there's this place
- where was it? The Bronx?
- Dapper Dan In Harlem
- In Harlem, alright. In Harlem where -
- Where you buy them, you
know, those knock-off stuff.
- (audience laughs)
- (interviewers laugh)
- Right, and he said this place would
it was a place where you
would go get fitted for suits
and it was open at three,
four in the morning.
And he said, "That might
sound weird to you"
but pimps, rappers, and
(chuckles) everybody else -
- Everybody, they was there. (chuckles)
- would go get suited at this place,
so that is why it was open that late.
And he said Mitch "Blood"
Green came walking in one day
and started, you know, calling
him all kinds of names -
- Holy moly
- And he (laughing)
- He said he was like a
zombie. He said he hit him.
And he broke his hand when he hit him.
And he knocked him (chuckling)
So he knocked him out dead.
And then he gets up like Jason.
- (audience laughs)
- And like a (laughs)
He says, every time he knocked-
- No, I mean, when I
knock him out, I'm scared.
So let's get to the car.
And the next thing I know,
(sung in ominous tune) bum, bum, bum, bum.
- (audience laughs)
- What the fuck?
I mean, do you believe this shit?
Am I right? Hand to God my children like,
he be - he (groaning). And I said,
"Let's get out of here."
Next thing you know,
(sung in ominous tune) du, du, du, du.
- Like, he keeps knocking this guy out
and the guy keep getting
up and chasing after him.
Out of the thing. And
then, the game changer is
he rips the mirror off
Mike Tyson's Rolls Royce.
And Mike has to get out
and knock him out again
before he drives away.
- (audience laughs)
- But when he tells the story -
- I wasn't going to let
him get away with that.
I wasn't going to let him
get away with that and
take my little Rolls Royce
and break the window off.
Break the little mirror,
the side mirror, right?
Yeah, ripped it off. -